les courants que vous voulez regroupent
et se sont souvent méfier de
l'électoralisme
pourquoi aujourd'hui cette entrée en
lice pour les prochaines élections je
crois que tout le monde ne peut que se
féliciter que des courants qui ont été
méfiant à l'égard des élections entre
aujourd'hui dans la bataille électorale
je pense que peut-être les expériences
du passé récent ont enlevé à beaucoup
certaines illusions et que par
conséquent
admettent danse excuses de grands fonds
qui a aussi une aile droite centre et
une aile gauche
les gens qui avaient peut-être des
tentations non électoraliste admettre
maintenant que la bataille politique se
déroule réellement à l'échelon
électorale et avec les méthodes
démocratiques vos affiches par leur
graphisme dans le slogan ressemble à
celle du msi des néo fascistes italiens
que faut-il en déduire je crois qu'il
faut pas tirer de conclusions de ses
graphismes identique
nous avons utilisé cette flamme
tricolore parce qu'elle nous paraît la
plus jolie qui avait sur le marché
graphique si vous voulez et quant au
slogan qui a peut-être été utilisé par
le msi et que nous utilisons il
correspond peut-être à une identité de
situations et de danger mais je puis
vous dire personnellement que je n'ai
aucun contact avec le msi italiens
encore que je ne vois pas leur action
avec antipathie dans la mesure où il
constitue une force capable de s'opposer
à la montée du communisme mais
personnellement je n'ai aucun contact
pour l'instant en tout cas avec les
dirigeants du msi
[Musique]